[موسيقى]
هي حب حياتي تشارلز منذ شبابه وزوجته خلال
العقدين الماضيين بعد اعتلاء تشارلز العرش
اصبحت الملكه القرينه لكنها بعيون الناس
كانت دائما المراه الاخرى كما ظلت دائما
محل مقارنه بالاميره ديانا زواجها من ولي
العهد لم يكن ضمن خططها المستقبليه ولا
ضمن توقعاتها حتى
فاجات تشارلز العالم بزواجه من كاميلا عام
2005 وكان ثاني زواج لكليهما لم تحضر
الملكه اليزابيث حينها الزواج المدني
ولكنها باركت هذا الزواج لاحقا كما علمنا
في وقت لاحق من خلال تصريحات هاري اللاذعه
ضد العائله بانه وشقيقه ويليام توسل
تشارلز الا يتزوج كماله لكن ذلك لم يردعه
حينها
كما ولدت عام
1947 لعائله غنيه ووالدها ضابط متقاعد من
الجيش ارتبطت بضابط في سلاح الفرسان يدعى
اند في منتصف الستينات لكنها تعرفت الى
تشارلز مطلع السبعينات ووقع في حبها منذ
اللحظه الاولى بحسب احد كتاب السيره
الذاتيه
ظل قريبا من كاميلا وزوجها السابق وكان
عرابا لطفلهما الاول تزوجت تشارلز ديانا
عام
1981 ولكن ظلت كاملا جزءا من حياته
وكلفتها علاقته السريه به صورتها امام
البريطانيين الذين لطالما نظروا اليها
كمخربه لزواج تشيلس بديانا
ففي مقابلتها الشهيره عام
1995 افصحت كنا ثلاثه في هذا الزواج
تلاقوا كاملا كان عام
1995 في حين انتهى زواج تشارلز وديانا
رسميا عام
1996 بعد وفاه ديانا عام
1997 انسحبت كاملا من المشهد لكن تشارلز
اصر على وجود كاملا في حياته ليتزوجا
بعدها في احتفاليه مدنيه صغيره في ظل
الجدل حول لقبها كملكه محتدما خلال حكم
الملكه اليزابيث التي منحت كاملا لقب
الملكه القرينه قبل وفاتها بعده اشهر خلال
الاحتفال بيبيلها البلاتيني
صوره كامل لاك قرينه للملك لا زالت مهتزه
وشخصيتها مثاره جدلا وانقسامات في الشارع
البريطاني قصر بوكينج حاول تحسين صوره
كاميرا امام عامه الناس وكمل بذل جهودا
حديثا للاعتراف بها في العائله لكن
بالنسبه للبريطانيين الزجاج المكسور لا
يعود كما كان ووفاه الاميره ديانا كسرت
قلوب البريطانيين الذي ينظر الكثير منهم
لكم على انها الملام في ماساه ديانا من
لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه بمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات